Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new spider-man 3 video tom hall trying
to do his darndest not to spoil the movie for a
couple minutes the spider-man 3 interview that
he did posting this video is actually way longer
so i'll explain the other stuff he said about the
movie during this for some reason they just cut
it down before they posted it if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there's going to be a bunch of spider-man related
stuff happening really soon and there's also a
bunch of big super bowl trailers that are coming
this weekend so we know about a couple marvel
ones that are coming i'll be doing videos for
all that stuff too the reason why he actually did
this interview in the first place is because we're
in the middle of movie awards season so he's
hyping up a couple of his projects spider-man
3 among them but he also did a movie with the
russo brothers separately from marvel called
cherry so he's hyping that up as well obviously
he's talking about spider-man 3 being their most
ambitious movie so far it's the third movie in a
trilogy obviously sequels have to escalate so you
would expect it to be even bigger than spider-man
far from home and because he's getting on in
spider-man years he's been playing the character
for a long time now people are starting to wonder
how much longer they're going to keep doing tom
hall and solo films so even though there are
rumors about them doing spider-man 4 with tom
hall like sony's already said they're making
a fourth spider-man film but we don't know a
lot about the plot yet because we haven't even
seen spider-man 3. they made a billion dollars
on spider-man far from home so of course they
want to get that billion dollars for spider-man
3 and how do you escalate things to guarantee
yourself a billion dollars you go full spider
burst so he did have some funny things to say
about all the andrew garfield toby maguire rumors
and the other big spider-verse stuff the internet
has been talking about for the past few months
since they started working on the movie he kind
of fumbled his way through a very similar type of
answer as he was giving when he was talking about
the ending of the movie like oh of course you
want me to give away the end of the movie and
i almost did i love the way he does come clean
about that during the video he says you almost
got me to answer all those spoilery questions but
he kind of fumbled his way through a tobey maguire
andrew garfield answer like the kind of answer you
would expect him to give when sony and marvel are
holding guns to his head outside of the zoom frame
while he's speaking i believe his answer and a
couple of the other cast members who've also been
asked similar questions about andrew garfield and
toby mcguire have all kind of said the same thing
mostly i don't know anything about that if they're
in the movie that would be great that sounds like
something that marvel would do like yes we know
about all these rumors we know what the internet
has been talking about all these posts that have
been going on and there was another reason andrew
garfield rumored just a couple days ago because a
delivery driver who was taking food to the set in
atlanta where they're filming spider-man 3 claimed
that he was delivering food to andrew garfield
so why would andrew garfield be near the set
of spider-man 3 if he weren't shooting a cameo for
the movie a lot of people also noticed during that
clip too tom holland is kind of misusing the term
standalone movie spider-man 3 is not a standalone
movie it's the third film in a trilogy but i think
the way he's using that term standalone he's just
talking about the separate solo spider-man
movies as opposed to avengers infinity war
avengers end game or movies like captain america
civil war where spider-man is only one of the main
characters instead of being the lead the follow-up
joke to that though is that spider-man 3 seems
like it's got so many characters in it even though
most of it is just all rumors and speculation
that it seems like tom holland's spider-man is
just a side character in his own movie like which
cameo are you most excited about i'm most excited
to see if tom holland is going to get a cameo in
spider-man 3. i've already talked about this in
the past too i think the idea is all this cameo
stuff whatever winds up being true most of those
people will just be small parts of the movie and
even without them they've already confirmed that
dr octopus from the tobey maguire spider-man films
in electro from the amazing spider-man andrew
garfield films are going to be in the movie their
confirm so you could call it a spider-verse movie
even without tobey maguire and andrew garfield
coming back i also got a lot of questions recently
about the viral spider-man 3 social account for
flash thompson so there's the spidey number
one fan account that's been posting a lot of
spider-man 3 stuff recently and it's actually real
it's not just a fan account pretending to be real
sony and marvel use it for viral marketing for the
spider-man movies they did it back for spider-man
far from home as well it was meant to be a viral
account created around the whole idea that flash
thompson is a spider-man stand like the number one
spider-man fan and just because the account has
been posting so much more the past couple of days
doesn't confirm that they're going to be doing
any kind of spider-man 3 super bowl trailer but if
they do release more spider-man related stuff this
weekend of course i'll do videos for it it's more
likely that they would release a venom 2 trailer
at the super bowl just because that movie's still
supposed to be coming in june it hasn't been
delayed yet so fingers crossed that that date
sticks the more recent posts from the account
though are all about j jonah jameson's daily bugle
posting more anti-spider-man anti-peter parker
stuff the way they frame it in these daily bugle
articles is that half the population believes
mysterio and thinks the spider-man is a criminal
and really killed him and the other half believes
that it's a fake video from the start that kind
of dovetails with a lot of the easter eggs that
we saw on the set a little while ago there were a
bunch of pictures of it that posted a couple weeks
ago i've already done a video about it but on the
message board here one of the easter eggs is for
a new organization that pops up called citizens
to defend spidey so it sounds like there'll be
a small time jump maybe when the movie picks up
or at some point early in the movie there'll be
a small time jump so that enough time will have
gone by for stuff like this to set in people will
have time to think about the video and the other
brand new easter egg that a lot of people have
been talking about is the feast truck that showed
up so even if you're not a big comic book reader
you probably saw the feast shelters during the
spider-man ps4 game and it also shows up during
spider-man miles morales but the fee shelters
were created by mr negative and it stands for
food emergency aid shelter and training so the
whole idea is that mr negative wants to become the
kingpin of crime in chinatown but also the good
martin lee's side of his personality wants to help
the community and that's the side that creates
the fee shelters i don't know if this means that
mr negative is supposed to be in spider-man 3 but
it's possible that they introduce martin lee and
then in a future spider-man movie they turn him
into mr negative and a lot of you will know that
wandavision is supposed to connect with spider-man
3 right now they confirmed that it's helping set
up some elements in spider-man 3 in addition to
a bunch of other future marvel movies there's all
kinds of theories but just based on what they've
done the past couple of episodes setting up the
concept for her alternate house of m reality and
the reality warping powers using cosmic radiation
like the infinity stones it sounds more like
the connection between the show in spider-man 3
is more to do with the blending elements of the
multiverse like i'm not expecting tom holland to
cameo during Wandavision spider-man isn't going
to show up to west view to investigate what's
happening with scarlet witch and you also have to
remember that the events of spider-man far from
home take place eight months after avengers end
game Wandavision takes place three weeks after
avengers end game so Wandavision technically takes
place a long time before the events of spider-man
far from home but just based on what we've seen
so far the sword agents and darcy from the thor
movies claim that the threat that is scarlet
witch's reality warping cosmic radiation powers
might eventually cover the entire planet and start
changing everything on the fly the way you saw her
accidentally changing things while she was in the
process of giving birth to her mutant twins from
the comics billy and tommy or wiccan and speed she
effectively created them out of nothing using her
cosmic radiation powers remember they explained
that it's the same type of energy that created the
infinity stones the same energy that they give off
when people use them to alter reality or aspects
of the universe jimmy wu was just wondering about
that amongst other really big questions on their
big theory whiteboard so post all your spider-man
3 theories about this in the comments how do you
think that Wandavision will set up spider-man 3 my
full Wandavision episode 5 video will post friday
just like normal so be sure to enable alerts
for my channel so you don't miss the episodes
and click here for my brand new Wandavision
episode 5 trailer and you can click here
for that brand new thor 4 love and thunder
first look with the guardians of the galaxy
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video!